hey what's going on it's bill bird it's
time for the Monday morning podcast for
Monday January 29th 2018 what's going on
oh I all right well this was a bore this
would have been a boring Sunday because
there was you know there's no football
right we got the you got the week off in
between in between the Superbowl and the
championship games they had the Pro Bowl
today which was kind of cool look like
football in the future where they would
gain you know they'd start to tackle
somebody all right all right all right
all right all right you know I know
that's the concussion thing or the me to
I don't know what it is he does not want
you touching him do not throw into the
ground I have a special guest to liven
up my Sunday day I thought you were one
of my favorite [ __ ] people in this
business and you were one of my favorite
comedians so is a pleasure did I feel
the feeling is mutual advantage or you
don't have to compliment the silliest
[ __ ] dude you make me feel mature
that's what I like about you Todd Rex
okay yes Todd Rex who checks off a lot
of boxes in this day of caring that's
right you do I don't even know that mean
I don't know what it means either I'm
just trying to be progressive you would
think that somebody would come his
[ __ ] way and finally tap the magic
wand on his head and make you something
happen and say Todd you've been
destroying at least three times as hard
as ten times is the [ __ ] or whatever
the math is all the [ __ ] comics out
there I love working with you but I hate
following you
he was [ __ ] murder finally this
[ __ ] [ __ ] you got himself a
special that he's taping and he needs
some people to come down and then you
can you know go on and I can open for
you make you sweat a little there no not
a chance
all right he's gonna be at the satellite
theater in Silver Lake the satellite la
comm for tickets that's fine
February 11th you're gonna be doing the
show it's just Sunday
but you should come out David support
thee alright Sunday which is a week
after the Super Bowl right so nobody
knows it was 7:30 and 9:30 two shows two
shows to show is to show so you're gonna
go out there you [ __ ] you knock the
first one out you go alright I got it
and then the next one you just go off
cruise is that what you do what you do
you're like you button the first ones
tightened up and then I spend the whole
night trying to forget that I'm taping
one really stop trying to think like oh
my god I missed that tag [ __ ] that
needed to be documented in the comedy
universe I just try to look at it like
alright this is just I'm just
documenting where my hour was on this
night and this is how it came up and I
want you to do that
because every night when you go up there
I don't know about you but I mean I'm
constantly [ __ ] up jokes
I'll constantly leaving [ __ ] out and
then it adds to something else right and
I never think of it never think about it
like I never thought to get you a glass
of water before you sat here for a
[ __ ] hour
what an idiot I might have to pause here
in a minute but no good
that's just how I had to do it that way
just cuz I wanted to think about you I
wanted to ask you about your thought
process because I was curious like I
know that the night before I'm gonna be
a wreck
you know just thinking about it all the
funny guys worried hacks don't worry X
are already [ __ ] working on their
next happy hour yeah they're not even
[ __ ] nervous to just and they'll go
off stage with this shitty material be
like dude I [ __ ] crushed I crushed
and every funny guys like I do that
every every time I just really don't run
about weight compliment to myself I know
I'm you know I got a ways to go people I
got a lot she's you're one of the big
beasts yeah so I summit told me I think
louis c.k told me and i think he heard
this from [ __ ] bill cosby how funny
was that he heard that you work this
hard to get there don't forget to have
fun right so make sure yeah cuz if
you're having fun that's gonna be you're
gonna feel better about it afterwards
right if you're someone who nitpicks at
himself there's no way you're gonna be
happy at the end of it so just be
forgiving
just be the [ __ ] silly [ __ ]
hilarious guy you are you'll be fine
yeah I'm not really too worried about it
I just want to make sure that I already
can tell you worry about it you see who
seemed tighter than usual geez did well
I'm doing your podcast it's kind of a
big deal for me too I feel like I didn't
the whole thing now that you've peeked
behind the curtain it's just me
what the [ __ ] $99 mixer from good
Santa but we're sitting here on the
couch like Ernie and Bert all I did to
prepare for you is I turned on the AC
and I squirted some Febreze that's it I
know everybody has these fancy [ __ ]
studios I just did I did your mom's
house with Tom Segura and Christina
Brzezinski I just did theirs and they
have this whole [ __ ] studio Rogan has
like a literally like a stern level
studio she's and I should step it up at
some point yeah but your house is dope
oh no no one can see it but your house
is dope oh thank you it wasn't when I
bought it but now that I've dumped all
this money into it and I could never get
my money back it's pretty good this
house was like almost a hundred years
old when I got it almost 90 years old
cool people live in here before though
right yeah I don't want to talk about
that though because then people will
[ __ ] figure out where I live I
already have to [ __ ] edit out one of
the comments you made earlier that will
do people are [ __ ] lunatics and
that's what I'll tell you later just it
was just enough of something to make
some psycho just turn around and face
his speaker and start writing down
information but I'm a paranoid dude yeah
anyways what was they talk what what the
[ __ ] were just talking about my a dee
dee I don't know either I have no idea
even watching any hockey did you see
marshawn's elbow look dude I was a thing
of beauty really it was a thing it was
so it was perfect filthy he got tripped
I know he's the size of Barney Rubble so
nobody he's not gonna get called out
like I awful is probably one of the
worst but dude he was and I love Marsha
and I love the [ __ ] bruise but I love
him good Marty's but I bet the thing is
I don't like that aspect like doing that
[ __ ] did you see when uh what I also ban
destroy them oh my god
I thought he had like internal bleeding
after yeah he was just going on and it
seemed like beyond the way the thing
about pk well I'm so glad he placed on
Nashville not from Montreal anymore it
was he used to he used to get us all the
time and everybody knew that was his
move I don't know why no one cuz he just
knew exactly when your head was down for
a second it was two crossovers he was
inside and then all of a sudden he was
just in front of you and he just ended
your [ __ ] life to like I don't know
like two shifts but yeah I'm I always
liked that guy and I never taken to the
to the point if there's a guy on a team
that I don't like you know like when
Derek Jeter played for the Yankees I
couldn't I couldn't get myself to get to
the point of like he actually hating on
it's like the guy's great right he's
good
yeah all you're saying is I wish this
guy was on my team my son playing hockey
he's a beast of course I know you showed
me all the video of them he like picked
it up and to see he was like playing
drums or something right they also play
the drums to any place drums any place
hockey kids gonna be crushed
you could be a [ __ ] grandfather by
the time the special comes out and I
jeez where you been working - uh I just
I just flew back today from Phoenix I
was with Craig Craig Robinson you know
I've been telling him for like a couple
years now when he's not shooting
television shows which is all the
[ __ ] time that guy works idea so yeah
where were you guys working we were
working at stand-up live in Phoenix okay
I know that place five sold-out shows it
was fantastic had a ball I did the you
know it's [ __ ] that's [ __ ] nuts so
as far as like that downtown area how
lively it is yeah if there's something
going on but the second the workday ends
like during the week if you're there
like at five o'clock no yeah it's
[ __ ] creepy
if the sons don't have a game right it's
over right yeah I love it though I mean
I couldn't live their own thing but I
had a really good time there I had a
good time traveling with you though we
went down south I was just like reading
some comments about the check in that
hotel and that lady was just [ __ ]
with the instructions my gym is on the
fourth floor it's open from 9:00 to 9:00
the Continental blood line like I'm
sitting there going like oh my god how
long is this gonna take
she got like offended she was bad for
real I [ __ ] was laughing like I was
in high school man it was one of those
laughs I was just like oh because what
it was was the fact that she didn't find
it funny right it was already hilarious
but the fact that she didn't find it
funny it hurt her feelings she didn't
have to deal with it then she got mad
all in like [ __ ] like a half a second
right then I felt like I was in class
again where it's like oh my god don't
start [ __ ] laughing or you're gonna
get like detention or something yeah you
also took me do that that [ __ ] was at
that barbecue place or something oh yeah
what does it call it was it they'll say
the name of it because it was terrible
well the first we went to that we went
to that one where it was a giant [ __ ]
place and they had like 40 fried
murdered chickens
that you can see you don't mean that
place it was gigantic you know oh my god
this place is [ __ ] unbelievable is
that the place where you ate and then we
went to the NASCAR track and then you
were like t-rex wish that you had a
salad was that enough I was in Charlotte
that was Charlotte okay and we did the
NASCAR experience that was very cool
though it was talking about crushing it
that dude was driving us around he's 20
years old named Dylan remember that I
know anyways as much as a jockey right
because he doesn't want to slow the car
down
I couldn't believe like what a
piece-of-shit a race car looks like when
you walk up to him I've seen Formula one
cars up close they look like absolute
like it looks like if you've stepped on
it the whole thing would fall apart cuz
all it is it's just it's just an engine
suspension and tires and everything else
is just the lightest right did you see
the gas pedal which is like a stick
there's a bent coat hanger it's like
like if you had like that's just the
floor thing whatever that the pedal is
to rest your foot on that's the
difference between you like I guess
winning the race or coming in like third
because that [ __ ] thing sitting there
piece of rubber those are the women that
race that actually there NASCAR's not
doing well that's not know and I went to
the Daytona 500 they painted the seats
like every other seat like they had like
three colors and they would paint them
but make it look like there's people in
the suit yeah cameras flying by and you
know used to have it like that was the
Minnesota North Stars really used to
have seats like that I thought it was
cool and now I'm thinking well maybe
because nobody showed up for the game
the devs and maybe that's why they moved
to Dallas so when I hear all those
Minnesota North Star fans still
complaining that their team left I mean
if there was people that well there was
people there I wouldn't have noticed
right exactly
they brought their skating on four
thousand lakes it
you want you to eat a football was that
you watch any of the football heaven I
have been watching any football the only
thing I like is the Washington Redskins
and their terrible number one I'll show
you from Baltimore hostia how did you
become a Redskins fan
I'm from Silver Spring Maryland right
over the DC line like people always
think wow okay but money no I grass and
shouldn't my art in cars both parents
are not saying that that's not available
Baltimore would people think of a wire
in the corner I'm gonna think about
Baltimore but that's not where I lived
oh that's why cuz that's where I met you
I met yet the Baltimore Improv with
[ __ ] debt long he had to walk down
like that 3/4 of a mile hallway those
are the that you want the last mile or
whatever yeah that was the worst
location ever for a for up for a [ __ ]
comedy club woody Club I was all
thrilled they let me come down there and
they asked me if I wanted to close out
the Sunday one time because somebody
cancelled that was all [ __ ] excited
and I drove there from New York City to
do it and I was like I'm gonna get in
with the Improv and I showed up and
there was like ten people there and the
owner talk was talking to the Booker
never talked to me and then walked out
while I was on stage and I remember
being on stage like I think I knew when
I was on stage because I was kind of
glancing over like okay well you know
these were subsonic burger and it was
really [ __ ] annoying I don't know why
anybody who ran a club why the [ __ ] you
would ever do that because you don't
know who's coming down right and for all
you know they're gonna go on you know
and do something the fact that you would
I was driving down from he didn't even
say thanks classic [ __ ] club manager
the fat big 50-inch [ __ ] waste so
much you know I mean let those slacks
that giant [ __ ] belt right gaberdine
whatever those flags call action slacks
yeah the action slacks yeah thanks dear
yeah I ran into a number of those
[ __ ] people that's my big thing
though this year do you know I'm turning
50 are you really turning 5-0 into 49 in
May you do
all right there young stuff behind you
do you want to know what the next year
your life is gonna be like
oh yeah hopefully it's gonna be
something like yours no well I've
decided that I'm gonna uh I'm gonna
[ __ ] uh get myself that like rather
than looking at 50 with dread which I'm
really not considering I you know so
many of my friends have [ __ ] died
didn't even make it so you know don't
tell me he died that's where I got it no
no we didn't see did last weekend last
Sunday he [ __ ] died yeah you know
what it was like some Carter cardiac
event one of his friends was like coming
from Connecticut going down to Florida
hadn't seen Jill in like 15 years stop
by his house and they're gonna go to the
Improv to watch
Lavelle Crawford and Joe said he had a
headache went upstairs it takes on my
gas when whatever as I said on the bed
and like laid back and croaked
while his buddy was there that he hadn't
seen in 15 years what yeah isn't that
crazy
oh my dude that guy had one of my
favorite [ __ ] jokes what about the
convo know the joke he did when he was
having unprotected sex with the woman
and you know because I'm doing my thing
I'm doing with things she goes Joe don't
you come at me don't you come and meet
Joe Joe goddamn you don't come he goes I
blocks all that out I haven't seen him
in [ __ ] I haven't seen him in like 15
years
ah [ __ ] yeah but we're getting into
that age where people are just dying and
say you know what's really [ __ ] up is
I know you know it's been dying that I
don't it's not even like shocking to me
anymore
yeah oh my god but I was at my son's
hockey game when someone called me and
it was like yo Joe recognize are you
serious he was like everyone said how
and he's like I don't know I'll find out
I was like I call me back I'm on my
son's hockey game well have years ago
you know whatever you know you know what
it is is the first wave that goes is
it's usually be bad genetics bad luck a
bad diet and then after that it's like
if you had half a bad diet
half a genetics just literally like when
the Grim Reaper's gonna get you so
speaking of that becoming a dad at this
point like I was [ __ ] old as I am I
got it you know I've cut back on the
boozing and so I'm trying to get myself
down to my [ __ ] to my fighting weight
and actually maybe get a person you look
fit yeah I I took four months off of
booze and then for the last month I've
been drinking like lightly but I don't
know I think I'm just too old now
because I took those [ __ ] four months
off and now going back to it just I get
to and then X I drink too and I'm just
like banged up the next day so I don't
know I I think I'm gonna go I was joking
that I'm gonna go I'm gonna be like
sting in my 50s just do like [ __ ]
Pilates and yoga and tantric say try to
learn how to come for 40 minutes that's
how a lot of his music is is record a
lot of people don't know that it's
actually him coming in the beginning of
synchronicity is that for the first 40
minutes then the last five minutes he
just sings the song and right as he
comes that's the hook geez I saw him
that I'm at the Hollywood Bowl with
Thomas said Gaylord Perry it's a picture
yeah who's the guy from Genesis that
sang sledgehammer Peter Gabriel yeah
they both were [ __ ] awesome and they
had like and I was like who's gonna hit
who's gonna open who's gonna [ __ ]
close and they just one would sing a
song and then the next one come out and
sing a song and then they were just both
out there and if it was the other person
song they would just sink back up really
oh yeah as though Peter Gabriel had like
synchronized dance moves and [ __ ] it was
[ __ ] me and they were bad but that
was part of the joke but you see was he
didn't give a [ __ ] like it was like two
guys like daughter players will do
sometimes is that right I was like the
violin and she comes out and crosses on
the violin
I'm trying to member if you get a
violinist I just know that he was just
like the guy who just aged and said [ __ ]
it right was staying was you know still
in shape and [ __ ] so later I look
terrible no dude he came out looking
like you know that headliner that didn't
make it it just doesn't give a [ __ ]
anymore comes out with like wearing like
the same sweat suit he was wearing when
you picked him up at the airport just
walks on stage maybe put a hat on
he had a big onesie on sting always has
one of those [ __ ] those clothes that
looks like he's gonna do uh was that
movie he did with Tina Turner where she
shaved the side of her head oh my god
Thunderdome Thunderdome I feel like he
got a bunch of clothes from that movie
that still fit him right he still has
the trailer the wardrobe trailer you
know that mesh spider-man looking [ __ ]
flashy underwear peeking out of the back
we're gonna change chainmail shirt yeah
well I saw those guys they [ __ ] they
absolutely killed it here I got to make
sure what 20 minutes then at some point
I do have to read a little bit
advertising put on dude who's your
[ __ ] Internet provider AT&T mine is
just it's just not happening for me yeah
I think I might I don't know who I have
Nia handles that and it's it's just been
on the fritz
I got it's right at the fridge it's been
on the fritz I got to drive over to
Starbucks buy something Starbucks I
don't drink coffee all right I mean I
guess sick the coffee has to be amazing
well I'm strong as it is you don't need
to be carefully oh you know I don't know
works like wired though I'm the worst
dude I I need like the reverse of that
but you go in there all that food just
sucks all their their food just [ __ ]
sucks all right let me let me be a
little advertising here how much how
much how much time you're gonna do any
special I'm doing an hour that's doing
it now it may be a little longer so we
can cut it down I'll do as little long
as I would do like whatever you want it
to be I would only do a little bit more
than that yeah because yeah it makes it
real life so much easier if you if you
want to do an hour special do like an
hour and ten all right then you usually
just lift a bit or two
the same guys that are shooting my
special shot when he Adams speciality
too soon and they said that uh the Oni
did like an hour and 20 minutes uh-huh
and that they wanted to cut it down to
an hour because Showtime wasn't buying
an hour 20 minute specials they're just
buying our stuff Wow then you got to
start killing your babies yes the horse
but he refused to cut it and so they
just took it in an hour and 20 so if you
watch the special that's on right now
that's on Showtime right now it's an
hour and 20 minutes geez it's only yet
I'm just telling the business which way
it's going Wow all this I would have
been like alright I'll cut it down
alright oh look talk about the challenge
of finding great talent well usually I
have a hack on here but this week I
found Tod Rex
thank you I found you unzip recruiter I
looked up hilarious guys shooting a
special and [ __ ] silver like our zip
recruiter knew there was a smile away so
they built a platform that finds the
right job candidates for you zip
recruiter learns what you're looking for
identifies people with the right
experience and invites them to apply to
your job if read by the wrong person
this would seem really racist wouldn't
it yeah
these invitations have revolutionized
how you find your hire in fact eighty
percent of the employees who post on the
John SIPP get a quality candidate
through the site and just want that you
got to do something interesting or they
won't listen to it and zip recruiter
doesn't stop there they even spotlight
the strongest applications you receive
so you never miss a great match the
right candidates are out there
zip recruiter is how you find them
business businesses of all side trust
sip for using their higher needs see now
you're doing now right now my listeners
can try zip recruiter for free that's
right just go to zip recruiter comm / /
that zip recruiter com
/ / zip recruit accom / / the smartest
way - hi
oh Jesus look who's here but up up up me
undies biondi's no more sweaty balls
beyond esmii undies you could buy him at
the [ __ ] mall I'm on my podcast with
Tod Rex he's shooting a special what the
hex go down and get yourself some
[ __ ] tickets and your balls will feel
great in these underwear alright you
want to look good fake Todd do you want
to look good with your significant under
the other I do this Valentine's Day you
want your [ __ ] junk to be sliding
around this is silky smooth [ __ ] here
then check out me undies matching pairs
would you ever do this with us unique
fun gift for you and your Valentine
they're the perfect balance of comfort
fit and exciting prints don't spend
another Valentine's Day giving the same
old gift
check out my undies com find the best
match for your match the undies are the
most comfortable and fun undies you and
your significant other will ever own
they're made from the softest materials
on earth we're talking three times
softer than cotton and I believe that at
this point because the cotton Lobby has
never debated this fetus foreskin it's
made out of fetus heart I heard that
that they dip in organic dyes so it
doesn't give you ball cancer this
Valentine's Day get your partner a gift
that's for the both of you order by
February 5th of 10:00 a.m. for free
standard shipping so your gift arrives
in time matching pairs are fun
thoughtful comfortable gift they're
going back in they should have ended it
right there it's a comfortable gift you
share with your significant other 100%
satisfaction guarantee me undies
guarantees you and your significant
other would love your matching pairs or
your money back you know what they
should do next year for they should have
everybody whoever sends in the cutest
picture a picture of them and their own
and their matching pairs gets a free tip
trip to matching Paris oh no matching
pair is nothing to get your 20% off that
was just an idea people that's not an
actual offer so no [ __ ] sent people
in with you guys or said with your spare
tire hanging over your silk johns there
long johns to get you 20% off your
matching pair free shipping on a percent
satisfaction guaranteed go to me undies
calm that's me and ease calm oh sorry
manatee saw calm / / that's me andis
calm / bird this will be the best
Valentine's Day gift that you will give
start matching your bottom half to your
top better half go to me undies dot-com
/ / right now
you know promotional here they gave me
some really yeah
did you rock I I definitely want but
they definitely they gave me the Greg
Louganis cut are the one of them West
Hollywood cut there so I I was not in I
was not in gay male shape when I got him
so I didn't that look good well I'm
trying to get it in as good a shape it's
those fellas down there but uh who he
stabbed the pit like that I want to get
in shape no I want to get engaged a
buddy might all he does is he just loses
like [ __ ] ten pounds and then he just
sort of push this down and shirt going
dude I look good you know you're like
Pat you stomach I think I think I'm
looking alright do you and your wife do
you guys do you guys have four kids of
course we do no do you guys you guys
celebrate Valentine's Day is there now
at this point no how long you guys been
together since 95 that's great man yeah
23 years yeah but it took me till 2004
to tie the knot yeah oh yeah what am I
sure she was the one there somebody is
is that like 10 years wait 2001 2004
2004 so that's nine years all right
it took me what it was dude it took me
nine years to really the [ __ ] yeah yeah
stupid I knew it nine months but I was
just like I don't know and then also my
wife was a little bit of a
commitment-phobe we're both like
commitment phobes yet totally like
relationship people so it totally worked
you don't I mean so he lived our whole
Sid and Nancy [ __ ] lifestyle for a
while you know not married no kids
partying had a great time we did hit all
the water parks
with the matching t-shirts yeah yeah
matching beyond decently it took me
forever to propose to her but I'm gonna
tell you why it why it happened I went
out partying with friends of mine one
night and I ended up spending in that
out in Virginia and I was on my way back
the next day like 10:00 a.m. and my wife
was furious she's my girlfriend at the
time we were living together and she was
furious and she called me and she
already left me a message when I checked
the message then she called me again
when we were driving home and so when I
picked up the phone and said hey I just
was out here thinking with my friends
the reason I was like I'm out here with
my friends that spreadeth and I was like
I was talking to a man I think I think
I'm ready to settle down and marry you
wow that was mad was she that you had to
come up with that she know that she
better cause she will now when she
listened to this no way dude I want to
get you in trouble so what did she do I
was like good idea what I have a fight
what I at home for for spending a night
out so yeah so that diffused the whole
like fight that was coming up and set
you up for another thousand more the
next year
I just went [ __ ] did I do it I finally
just realized yeah I just knew she was
gonna leave no some days when I was mad
at her I would fantasize about breaking
up but even in the fantasy of her
breaking up when she would walk out even
in the fantasy of that I would still go
no I gotta make yeah yeah that's that's
that was the Paul virzi to help me get
through that Paul virzi has actually
helped a number of comedians get over
that like that's that's thing you know
you think it's a mountainous you just
stepping up on the curb or it's just
like dude where you going right what do
you know she's gonna be so happy you're
gonna be happy once you get through the
[ __ ] vows and all of that [ __ ]
then you just had a party with all your
friends and his [ __ ] greedy was he
was 100% one out of a said [ __ ] right
so I was gonna ask you do you guys go
out on Valentine's Day no we don't
really celebrate like what I'm gonna
talk about like they had our cards you
know you might
you know we have the kids so a lot of
the times we're just would wait till the
kids go to sleep and then we'll like
have a bottle of wine and watch a movie
or something downstairs some corn like
that no that's way better we're going on
out and go out there like dude we're so
old now sometimes it feels like we want
to go out have a good time so we're like
we go out and dinner and then go into
Hollywood and get some drinks and maybe
go to a dance club or whatever that by
the time we're done eating dinner really
we'll just go home and it's how psyched
eat when the other person says that I
don't want to go to Hollywood right now
yeah I I for years would rather drink at
home I got better stuff here then they
got out of the bar they always have some
[ __ ] stuff that's not a rape you on the
price falls oh yeah and once you're with
the person you're gonna be with that
they got the worst booze I'm not
interested in meeting anybody right so
all I'm gonna do is go out there and
then I got a deal with like how am I
getting [ __ ] home this is before like
uber and all that [ __ ] I've been I've
been drinking at home yeah for four
years new year so yours I have some like
yeah we have what bourbon diet bourbon
whiskey God and like I think it's a
tequila yeah there's really smoky I
think whiskey one time I was here didn't
you I was probably a scotch gosh yeah I
was it good yeah it was good oh do we
smoke cigars ah oh no no I don't think
we did because I was I was thinking my
daughter just had a first birthday and I
was looking at the house like and to do
that we had like 16 kids over here
really all our friends have kids now
because you know once you have a kid all
your friends who don't have kids it's
just like they keep living that Rockstar
life and you're like you just you get
like six more calls like I gotta watch
the kid just fade out and start yeah
they start disappearing or Verizon you
just fade out like that band member
who's on the first album whatever
[ __ ] after that go ahead then they've
been you know they never see that guy
into like the vh1 behind the music he's
just why
I don't even know they're putting out a
second album they just never called me
at all of a sudden I was just like
reikus get some out yes so I was looking
around the living room and I we had like
like 16 little kids in their ages yeah
and just like toys galore and just [ __ ]
all over the place and I was just
looking thinking like you know 18 months
ago this would have been five of my
friends we would have been getting
shit-faced watching a game and smoking
cigars and just huh like how much it
changes in a good way like we went to
the went to the park today for the first
time I went over put her on the swing
and [ __ ] she loved it
right is scream it's the greatest yeah
yeah pictures of video that man because
the highness it goes by so fast and you
look back at those pictures with the
tear in your eye oh I know no I'm
already doing it I'm already like this a
part of me that's like his psyched as I
am to be a dad there was a mild
depression with her turning one breath
going like she's not a baby anymore man
she's had taught them next year she
turns to her age doubled in a year yeah
she's no but I see why people keep
having babies because you just want to
keep hitting reset right because it's so
[ __ ] awesome and I like talking in a
positive way about it because when my
wife got pregnant just so many people
set all this negative [ __ ] I was just
like yeah this is way better than that
[ __ ] though yes now today we were over
there and I was just like I was having
the best time and I you know it was yeah
it was like good clean fun was actually
getting a little bit of exercise
clean and then she kind of took her
first step in the park which was cool
and so yeah so now we figured out what
the motivation tactic was to get it
going dude I'll tell you what's [ __ ]
up that was Eman is the definition of
organic in the deaf in the dictionary
versus the definition of organic within
the food industry like they literally
changed it like with law what organic
means because I know
we're giving her like poisonous [ __ ]
rose she's [ __ ] so excited to eat it
like no no no no no the [ __ ] that they
call inorganic but it's really got like
[ __ ] this like like they try to get
you addicted to it like cigarettes right
the same [ __ ] thing so we had these
little puffs that said organic on them
and I just noticed that like we would
have like really good food and she would
start pointing at the other ones like a
lab rat and then one time I went to
reach just reach for the can and she
started like hopping up like yeah yeah
so yeah we phased those out I'm actually
that's not true we have we have one more
can down so we're gonna wean her off and
then you know she's a kids like she
doesn't see it she's not gonna be
thinking of them but that's the thing
that's uh that can also drive you nuts
is that type of [ __ ] and then if you
have any sort of friend with a kid in
your life that is totally up on all
these issues they just they just come to
you it's like a [ __ ] it's like this
cloud of fear that they just dump on you
go to this website you have to [ __ ]
reinvent that and I've we have friends
like that or at least a couple and
they're [ __ ] annoying and it's like
and even though our kid likes their kid
we have to like cut them back a little
bit and like my daughter was like well
when is she coming when I'm like if the
King comes over it's fine but I can't
have the parents come over here to like
did you get your kids vaccinated how do
you how do you handle it because that's
what I realize now is that you can have
like you can be friends with people like
a couple you and your wife are friends
with a couple and then all of a sudden
and they have kids but you don't have
kids so you're not dealing with them on
that level but then when you have a kid
the relationship changes now you not
only do you guys have to like get along
socially when you go out you know yeah
you both vibe you got to kind of on some
they got to be within your wheelhouse
of how they raise their [ __ ] kid and
if the kid comes over he's a [ __ ]
lunatic like biting the dog and [ __ ]
like going what what is this caveman you
got to kind of be like I don't want my
kid acting like that right
I'm not saying any names I don't need
any people that are might be listening
to this but we have one family who has a
kid that's just [ __ ] rude and I I
can't have it yeah and I just I cannot
stand but my my kid wants this kid to
come over and we're always like Jesus
Christ
should we let this [ __ ] kid come over
and then like maybe they changed over
the last six months and they come spend
the night and it's a [ __ ] nightmare
what what are the rules if a kid comes
over and he's rude like what can you say
now to a [ __ ] kid did I started just
getting serious all I dude go back to
bed go back to bed stop [ __ ] waking
up every 10 minutes and calling for your
mommy and then when I see my dad I'm
gonna call your mom I don't say [ __ ] no
no because I don't know how I'm not
gonna be a woman shut the [ __ ] up you're
being a [ __ ] [ __ ] right stop being
a little [ __ ] don't decide I tell my
wife I'm I do if you get something one
more time I'm not talking to him you
gotta talk to him because I'm gonna
start getting mad
do you have it back in the day like if
your friend's dad said anything you
thought you were afraid of odd yeah hell
yeah go back to the room we'll go to bed
like oh [ __ ] this [ __ ] serious
that needs to come back I hate that they
call me by my first name
tied no they don't say that Todd I'm
scared
can you call my mommy now I'm old school
I'm old speed called me mr. Burke right
that's it let me [ __ ] it bill what's to
eat here what the [ __ ] did you say to me
you little [ __ ]
I won't say that but that's what I'll be
thinking so that course as I say please
address me is mr. burr the subtext he
will hear is what the [ __ ] did you say
to me you little [ __ ] and then he'll say
to his mother right yeah this one good
little girl comes over to our house and
she was like still coming downstairs I
sleeping all morning and then come down
in the kitchen with my wife and I are my
daughter's still asleep and she'll come
downstairs before everybody and she be
like what's for breakfast and my wife
was like well you know pancakes and
sausage she was like yeah I don't like
that stuff what else is there and my
wife just looks at me is like this [ __ ]
serious right now
the [ __ ] back upstairs okay what the
[ __ ] oh my I would love to hear a kid
now you say it to my mother all right
my mother would just be well that's all
there is I guess you know I'll talk to
you at lunch that's what my wife some
bosses I guess you'll just be hungry
thing because that's what we're having
and if you're in if you don't eat it
just be hungry
it's amazing held like some of these
kids are rude is [ __ ] them you say
something the parents like yeah she's a
little crazy
she's like no no that's that second
people have a dog that's [ __ ] nuts
like I did but I quarantined the thing
when people would come over except one
time I got a little confident I watched
you mean the dog whispers and then my
friend getting bit j-law I had got bit
by my dog yeah
bit him on his cap get my nip that's
always get a little [ __ ] out of me one
time we were downstairs there she was in
the cage oh yeah I was like went out the
case of the Battle of the caves and
scared the [ __ ] piss Island oh yeah
oh my god decades of the dog be shredded
right now yeah yeah she was an adorable
hellhound she loved the hell out of me
and about six people and everybody else
she treated as a [ __ ] intruder and I
just you know it was the smartest most
painful decision I ever made but I
didn't understand that I was still gonna
guess our you know the last two days in
a row she's in town right yeah that's
good that you kind of still take care of
her in a way right oh yeah oh yeah yeah
yeah and I get pictures of her all the
time and when like once every two months
she'll come to town and I just take her
for a hike every single day does she
remember you like yeah she did she does
she does and if when I when I go out to
where the guy lives if I show up she's
kind of look because she's not used to
seeing me then you know first they see
the shape and it's to smell like the
whole way the dog brain works or
whatever right and then then you know
then she's all back to normal everything
but I got a I was nervous meeting her
because of the way she was because I
knew at that point she bonded with the
new person and it might view me as like
a threat I mean the dog was like through
that dog my buddy said that there are
firs e yeah
virzi goes through there should be a 30
for 30 on that dog that dog's life like
how it was abandoned by the LA River I
mean so many times this thing should
have just been like you know like
whatever the Olympics come around they
always have like those crazy stories
that make you tear up all the [ __ ] that
they went through like you could do that
yeah and like as a pit bull being that
big of a pain in the ass like that those
things if those things sneeze they get
put down it's [ __ ] terrible but the
fact that she's still like living this
awesome life makes me feel good and
every time I see her like you know the
dude who got him is my former trainer so
and he he just like she has her first
dog friend now every dog she tried to
murder now she's like friends with the
dog but like they needed like his level
talent like as he says jokingly said
yeah I've been slow cooking her she's
not someone that you like okay this is
how it is and then boom to that it's
just been this year-long thing that
she's now finally ready to just and even
when he started hanging she started
hanging out with another dog there was
this whole [ __ ] process that he had
to go through and and totally keep an
eye on my dog because my dog does his
[ __ ] where like when she's going to
attack she's in the cage haha she did
that [ __ ] but she was out in the open
she just made the decision there was no
growling there was no warnings going run
she just did it
she just yes she would just [ __ ] do
it let me read let me read some of the
questions here all right talk by the way
you're kind of you're kind of [ __ ] I
can already tell dude you're already
wound up about this thing you're gonna
[ __ ] murder dude thank you I'm
excited about I really am yeah I feel
like this is like for so long and I'm at
the age right now like if it doesn't
[ __ ] pop for me right now it's not
gonna think it happen no that's that's
the old dude that's the old way of
thinking you're totally in control right
I view this business like it's a giant
mall okay and I have my little store in
the mall and you walk into my store hey
like you don't when I tell jokes I do a
podcast right got a cartoon see anything
you like that's what I'm selling if you
don't [ __ ] like it I get it
right see you later but when I
first got into this business I would you
know it's like you're walking around the
mall oh my god they're selling shirts I
gotta sell shirts
oh they got sneakers I gotta be do you
tried it like do ever but the Jones is
right yeah [ __ ] that too just by the way
your cartoon is [ __ ] hilarious now
thank you Frank Murphy and Victor my two
favorite guys oh yeah you wait to the
you wait to see you wait for the third
season where ruff oh no we're editing
editing like feeds it's going to be out
later on this year I'm not allowed to
say exactly when I don't have an exact
date either but like Netflix has like
you know they like the [ __ ] geniuses
of this new thing as they they I
remember the last like well last time
when I had a special coming out there
they wanted me to come in to meet with
them to like talk about discuss
promoting it and I'm thinking like what
the [ __ ] we going to discuss throw up a
couple of billboards I'll talk about my
podcast dude I went in there it was like
Bill Belichick [ __ ] delay yeah I can't
even I can't even explain it like I went
in there going like this is ridiculous
that this is just an idiot like me with
a bunch of dick jokes and then I just
like I watched them breaking down how
they were going about promoting it right
like to people who are watching Netflix
and their [ __ ] algorithm and all of
that [ __ ] judged by what you watched and
all that [ __ ] not saying it's a perfect
system for yeah it blew my mind [ __ ]
blew my mind that didn't do there's a
reason why they're global right now and
it's not from hanging out with me there
all right
peach cobbler recipe hey Billy crusts
King I like to bake by the way really
yeah my daughter
I made my daughter a birthday cake I'm
doing that every year of election easy
are you doing the non GMO with the no
gluten then non tasty frosting now now
that was a bunch of sugar and [ __ ]
nice stuff runs off yet baby seals in it
that's a big politically incorrect cake
yeah all right dip really crust King I
am invited to a Super Bowl pie
by the way you know the Patriots are in
it again this year yeah do you realize
if Tom Brady what gets another ring
Jesus Chris him and Bill Belichick will
have more rings than every franchise in
the NFL except for the Pittsburgh
Steelers they'll be tied well
and in their entire 50 years raising 50
something years of every franchise
trying to win one that Brady doesn't
lose the whole just let you know that
right now oh yeah he does he lost twice
to the Giants I think this is gonna be
it just give him the ring no no no no no
that top makes me nervous
through the Eagles the Eagles got a
[ __ ] horrific horrific league
terrifying [ __ ] running game yeah and
Nick Foles is not a backup quarterback
that is a starting quarterback who lost
his [ __ ] job and he's coming back
like a [ __ ] revenge movie that
defense looks looks [ __ ] great right
and I don't think we would have done to
the Vikings what they did so okay yeah I
don't know I would say take me just
trying to be humble there to keep the
gods every take the Eagles and the
points that's what that's what I would
do with my money now dude Edelman's out
Gronk out a concussion Amendola had the
game of his [ __ ] life did you hear
that saw me Amendola song it's like that
song Lola really do this [ __ ] go do
LA though now that player Nick Foles in
the Super Bowl
that's for it it may not show all right
hey Billy crest King I'm invited to a
Super Bowl don't worry just dudes and
nobody interested in commercials or
halftime shows thank God and I am the
designated dessert maker you were
talking about peach cobbler on a Monday
morning podcast but I can't quite
remember if it was a recent one or an
old one anyway would you mind sharing
your recipe with me because I want to
have the real deal I'm from Germany and
can't figure out if the recipes I find
here are any good I hope to hear from
you and go [ __ ] yourself I just googled
and looked at pictures and then I found
one that looked good this is this is
what I would say I would say I would say
if the cinnamon nutmeg whatever they
tell you to [ __ ] put in add more
because it always be like 1/8 of a
teaspoon a quarter they're gonna make it
taste good but they're not going to make
it taste great so definitely be tasting
your filling and don't be afraid to get
a little lie a little heavy
with some of the spices especially the
cinnamon sugar a little bit of some
butter in there and then I give it a
little dusting before I close the pie up
there oh yeah you got it it's got to be
a big [ __ ] delicious gooey mess
that's how I do it dude everything's
[ __ ] baking I'm trying to get you all
right political relationship advice
well good here we go all right I mean I
want to hear this one
I literally unfollow people on Twitter
if all they do is talk politics yeah
unless you're rationally kind of trash
on both sides but like you know if it's
gonna be like you know so are Trump just
did this well I mean yeah I mean Trump
excited for doing Conan Conan O'Brien
had the funniest [ __ ] joke about
Trump bingo how do you handle the whole
Trump sitch what's the hardest part
about the Trump situation right now he
goes it's because trying to write a joke
that's more absurd than what's actually
happening I like how am i Trump on
Twitter it's just considered normal now
that like a president has the time I
don't even like people [ __ ] on me all
the time I don't even get back to him
right
watching the quote leader of the free
world just so you know that wasn't a
stain on my tie that was actually a
presidential seal there all right
political relationship advice okay Billy
Willy [ __ ] [ __ ] I don't know what that
means that's a no one with a little bit
of alliteration two pair love the
podcast and of course the stand-up thank
you you're the only comic that actually
makes me bust out laughing Wow wait T
see Todd special so I'm a 21 year old
guy and I've been seeing this girl now
for about nine months
she's great treats me good loyal and is
pretty all of these relationship things
there we start off like a horror movie
well that was all sunshine everything 21
prime of my life by the good darkness
ooh
everything's going great all right the
main problem I have though is she is a
big Democrat big Democratic it's problem
is she's a big Democratic and he's a
super conservative she's black and I'm
almost as white as you Wow god this is
like a [ __ ] bad
she gets upset when I post political
stuff on Facebook like pro a pro video
of Trump but yet she posts all this
stuff about kneeling for flags and Obama
is all that yeah dude this dis
relationships not gonna [ __ ] last
it's doomed she wouldn't even talk to me
when I wore a trump shirt all right yeah
it's like dude like this is this is a
guy who like sort of saw how the Nazis
were baited into running over somebody
with a car going well you know there's
hatred on both sides dude I really
wanted to side with you but you know
this is this is like astoundingly
[ __ ] like this I respect the fact
that you like Trump and all of that [ __ ]
you want to wear his t-shirts but your
confusion that she gets upset is a
little [ __ ] weird it pisses me off
but I don't want to ruin the whole
relationship over something as dumb as
politics that's too late though since
you are already in an interracial
relationship and for a and for a lot
longer than me
period what's your advice question mark
the lovely Mia
it's Nia with an N can tell me her two
cents as well even though she'll just
side with the chick just kidding thanks
and as always go [ __ ] yourself PS Tom
Brady's the greatest of all time sir I
got to be honest with you like if you
don't understand why she is upset you'd
have to try to put yourself in her
position and then read some of this [ __ ]
in some of his opinions I guess would be
the best way to do it but like you're
not just a conservative if you like
rockin the t-shirt like you're all in
you know what I mean like
but my Jewish girlfriend hates when I
wear my swastika to serve do you think
that's it's that bad I mean he has he
hasn't run like I mean no but I see like
is he like a trump oh he's like a Hitler
light
what kind of booze would Hitler be was
that there's got to be like moonshine
so where's Trump City bourbon going
slugger
yeah he's like a little bit of flakes
instead of gold place yeah Johnny Walker
red there's no filter
yeah there's no [ __ ] thought whatever
soft Drake - [ __ ] mix with it what's
the worst when you were broke is what's
the worst beer you ever had yeah
college-aged Milwaukee's best now why
wouldn't that or natty Boh national
bohemian it was pretty damn bad oh you
know what I always hated was [ __ ] uh
bush light well
Bush light was like Bush itself was just
yeah that was just like yeah it was like
water and then they watered death now we
used to East I never you know something
I never got into Pabst Blue Ribbon
because I resented the hipsters that
we're drinking them because it used to
be this blue-collar beer that all these
[ __ ] townies drank and then all these
hipster people were wearing their
flannel shirts well you know those
shirts for a while were they wearing
like the gas-station shirt that had
somebody else's name on it where they
actually had to do the [ __ ] job and
they found in some thrift shop like my
fantasy was that they ran into the guy
who owned the shirt and they just walked
up like yeah hey I'm Jim you know it's
my fault
oh I just thought you needed a shirt and
then it gets the [ __ ] kicked out of them
but most of my fantasies are violent my
advice is to I don't know get a bunch of
empathy I don't I don't I don't see this
thing working
I just don't see it working that's gonna
be like because you guys are so if
you're that far away from each other
you're not going to get married and have
kids no yeah that's like you yeah
they're fighting over them politically
too like so they're gonna be Democrats
and conservatives when they grow up
rifle that's a whole other can of worms
yeah so enjoy banging her and she lets
you while she likes you and then I would
[ __ ] here I would just be like yeah
but he's also 21 he doesn't know he
generally seems like he doesn't
understand unless that was just you know
sometimes people just lying there
writing crazy [ __ ]
alright girlfriend drinks too much dear
bill I was hoping you could help me out
with the problem I've been having I've
been living with my girlfriend for
almost a year now we were in a mid to
late 20s just for some background
everything's going great except for one
thing we worked regular 9:00 to 5:00
5:00 type jobs which means most of the
fun we have is on the weekend and like
most people we tend to lube up on the
liquor while we're out and about or even
just staying in well I don't think
there's anything wrong with with
drinking my girlfriend doesn't know her
limits often she will drink way too much
too early and end up passing out or
throwing up though commonly both will
occur Wow
yeah she doesn't not a drink you got to
pace yourself out there a few examples
she will insist on watching a movie
after we've had a few drinks we finally
decide we'll put it on and then after 15
minutes she passes out and then I'll
have to stop because of course I can't
watch it without her yeah well we'll
teach her a lesson watch the whole movie
and be like you missed a great one and
in the end the butler did it so lay off
the booze cuz I'm gonna start [ __ ]
doing that to you
number two we went to a hockey game a
few weeks ago and when we got to the
arena she ordered me a beer and herself
to double gin and tonics oh my god yes
she has a problem we had already had a
couple before arriving she then
proceeded to down both of them in ten
minutes before the puck drop and passed
out soon after a hockey game my god
that's a [ __ ] problem I had to drag
her up to stand for the anthem and again
when they were honoring
troops this is [ __ ] this is like a
Kristen Wiig character she then left for
the washroom that's one of my favorite
scenes though when she gets [ __ ]
wasted on the plane and bridesmaids yeah
and she just goes when she goes mother
[ __ ] she's walking out I see then left
for the washroom but came back with two
more double gins a hot dog in a bag of
popcorn which she spilled and blamed it
on me oh my god sounds like episode of
intervention even if I did do it the
first thing you're going to do is snitch
on me alright that just took a left turn
get the [ __ ] out of here was supposed to
be a team but I digress sorry for the
rant last weekend my god these are all
like bullet pointed by the way in the
over ride home sheep reprieved she
proceeded to whip out her tit to try and
seduce me I told her to put it away
because she was in no condition and I
didn't want to [ __ ] up my uber ad passes
out wait what the passenger gets an uber
any yeah pass was given ratings to for
the drivers that might actually boosted
his rating if the driver were to look
back and saw a sloppy titty thing we
[ __ ] gin-and-tonic on it anyway
they're gonna [ __ ] up my uber a pet she
passes out 30 seconds later and pukes in
the elevator on the way up to the
apartment it didn't make it a lot it
didn't make a lot of a mess as she was
able to hold it back before I got it to
the toilet oh this guy's just truncate
the piece de resistance she passed out
during the bilborough's show at the Sony
Center how do you pass out for that
creep man who just came in to entertain
us just a preface I had an allergic
reaction that morning was toast had a
little bit of weed before the show and I
was able to be fully alert but yet you
are the one that's falling asleep Jesus
Christ this is like the [ __ ] war in
peace this is like barfly saying all
this however I have to admit that I'm no
saint either I arguably drank much more
than she hired Lee we drink much more
than she does but I
my boobs a little better than she does I
probably made her sound worse than she
actually is he drunken mess yeah but in
truth she's a wonderful girlfriend who
cooks with me for me to lean for me it's
very beautiful
well in [ __ ] live happily ever after
but she's got three sheets she's not
puking on the sheets and as you can tell
is willing to come to a hockey game with
me and yes she did buy me bill bird
tickets to my birthday she's a truly
amazing person and I plan to marry her
someday but this is just getting out of
hand
and I want my weekends back can you do
me a favor and turn that light on my
[ __ ] eyes are shot here got the sun's
going down here I'm not trying to have a
romantic podcast with you let's see here
I've had conversations with her before
and when she's sober she gets it but it
doesn't stop her when she's drunk and
she would get angry at me when I tell
her she's had enough and I can't stop
her from sneaking off to get secret
drinks with my money she feels bad and I
honestly feel guilty writing this to you
and she is truly amazing I feel like he
brought the first half and then she
walked into the room and is looking over
his shoulder but it's tough not only for
me but I know this is not easy on her
but something her body sometimes as well
I just wanted her to be alright and for
us to be able to have a good healthy
time I'm not quite sure what to do here
am i right to tell her that she's got to
take it easy particular when we go out
because it seems to be working
do I have to set a better example and
drink less if at all yeah I mean if
she's a [ __ ] booze out maybe maybe
both maybe it both try to uh drink a
little bit less she might be one of
those people you know where once she has
a kid she'll just [ __ ] knock all that
[ __ ] off or oh god I could just drive
aromatize completely or she just stays
hammered all the time yeah you'll have a
drunken baby you know coming out [ __ ]
stop emailing at Billboard start
emailing Penske
kid comes out dressed like foster Brooks
to do a [ __ ] Bronx I love pasta drive
the the stimulant drug community yeah
yeah it's [ __ ] hilarious and he and
he never really drank that's back when
like being an alcoholic was like funny
right this is up this is how much I have
to be careful though is talking about
all that drinking made me want to drink
right like I love it I [ __ ] I hate
how it makes me feel though now so I
kind of like I just lay off that Craig
Craig Robinson to drink for a year and
then we just had drinks and Arizona this
past weekend we felt like trash both
mornings they would go yeah and so he
was like yeah I thought I was back after
taking the year up I thought I was back
up good on drinking I think I was like
yeah man I don't feel good either I had
a headache every day though it's it's an
age thing like it's really it's a young
person thing like it it like we had
thought we were down like we do those
shows those theater shows and we would
go to like the cigar bars oh yeah I have
a drink with cigars yeah yeah you know I
still like I think what I might drinking
maybe will be is like this year when I
go on the road I think like if I go up
for three days like that middle day yeah
not the first night because I traveled
and not that not you know the night
before I have to go to the airport but
just that middle one finding a good
place I don't know that that might be
the that might be the way I'll dude you
know I went to last night oh my god I
went to this [ __ ] this 80s like all
these bands this crazy [ __ ] lineup
was the real band was a tribute band
no it was like dude it was what was it
like dramarama remember them holy [ __ ] I
think I can't remember the song is that
flock of seagulls
the Romantics they were all really there
tone loke Oh
[ __ ] The Violent Femmes Melly melon
then the Furious Five for as well and
Boy George closed no way it was [ __ ]
it was this this was at the Microsoft
Theatre which used to be the Nokia me
and Nia went down there and it was
[ __ ] awesome but I learned a lot
about show business watching those puke
oould tell like who is sick of singing
their hits and it was also like [ __ ]
this I'm bringing it or and then I also
learned you know watching you know you
got to take care of yourself I almost
worry about that because I swear to god
dude if you see a band that let
themselves go it's like depressing like
yours because you love them and they
look like [ __ ] and then all you're
thinking is like oh my god um oh I'm
[ __ ] 20 years older than he was when
he put that song out [ __ ] we're all
gonna die
but when you just see a band come out
and they kept themselves in shape and
they're [ __ ] killing it as much as
they older it's it's like like I'm not
gonna name names but I saw one band that
made me think like dude I'm never
drinking again and then ice when I saw
the Violent Femmes yeah like dude they
just came out and was just a [ __ ]
tight sick ass bit like I watched em I
was like man I want to go play drums I
want to practice I want to get better
like there was nothing like negative
about watching the bay just came out and
find a four they went on after melly-mel
and uh bruised five who [ __ ] killed
right and you couldn't be more of a
different band like literally after the
stage would just turn oh yeah that's
badass they did that I already a music
festival thing they have like the band
with the stage of rotate 180 yeah and
then
the band and then they'd do the set
dressing behind and then the woods
keep turning to I guess I loved it I
loved it they got like down in Anaheim
they had it in like salt and pepper was
on and a couple of people it was [ __ ]
nuts it was you just knocked out like
ten of the Bands that I should have seen
back then and you know they all sounded
great there was just well I'll tell you
off it was just one person that I looked
at and it was just like my god but he
was still singing great but it's just
like [ __ ] dude we saw a cameo like six
months ago
down I can't remember what it's like by
the water somewhere here in LA and Roger
Troutman
I remember Roger Blackman wasn't it yeah
what songs does he sing she's our break
oh yeah okay dude he used to come out
like leather chaps and a cup you know
70cm [ __ ] coke spoon around his neck
to do he's still doing this still
weren't accompanies like his leather
pants the back looked like a diaper be
sexy and swivel his hips up my wife was
died laughs and she was like he needs
the fungus table yes stop stop doing
that nobody even when you keep yourself
in shape you can't do that sexy [ __ ] and
then I'm telling you that is a
self-involved baby boomer thing that is
being passed down like do Madonna is an
un-fuckin'-believable shape for her
[ __ ] age but when she starts twerking
it's just like doing right you can't
yeah and then it's like the older guy
what you got to do is you got a like I
stuck to DeRosa about this you know you
had a dress like Dana White when you get
older right like Dana White is roughly
my age Dana White you know he wears a
suit he wears to college sure it doesn't
have the title I always a little bit
relaxed but he's dressed like he doesn't
look like a creep you know what I mean
but if he was to show up you know what I
mean I'm not just putting it on him I'm
just saying that that [ __ ]
look just but you take a guy the same
age my [ __ ] age and you're gonna try
to [ __ ] pull off like a tank top like
even like when you watch these these
those p90x things right 58 year old guys
with the ABS it's like dude bubbly
amazing putting your [ __ ] shirt on
because there's nothing they could do
for the loss of elasticity and your
[ __ ] skin right yeah you're
decomposing in front of me little fruit
flies flying around you so I learned a
lot like I watched those bands and it
was the people that were comfortable
with their age and kept themselves in
shape and came out and what having a
good [ __ ] time oh yeah it was just
like ah man this is [ __ ] grand you
look like you just were really excited
but if they came out like you know
they'd [ __ ] this this still [ __ ]
party and like you know Keith Richards
back in the day and then they're coming
and you're gonna still wear like leather
and [ __ ] right HDNet have this council
series a couple years ago and they were
so these commercials for the hit for the
concert series and they would show they
showed Steppenwolf right and then that
middle section that goes on for [ __ ]
ever remember used to work in a
warehouse [ __ ] the second Delic part
yeah goes on for two sorry I interrupted
your story that's right but they would
show like dem plank counselors back in
like the 70s and it'll be jam-packed
arena and people going crazy in the
crowd and then they show up now like it
was smash cut from then to now now
they're playing on like an outdoor stage
and only about 300 people are sitting on
this lawn in like lawn chairs I know
because we're old - well yeah all the
people that love it back then are old
now - so I was like watching people
perform at like Shady Acres retirement
community I know what those guys are
like 70 I know it's [ __ ] I'm sure the
guide the band still sounds great in
everything but it's got me
they're just like [ __ ] we still have to
make money only yeah what a lot of those
guys they got they got so stolen from
just completely ripped off and then you
add that if somebody got divorced and
[ __ ] yeah you're gonna be singing that
song oh I just realized I crossed my
legs wearing slippers in front of you
I'm sorry
those are great slipper they are great
slippers no I finally bought some new
socks and I just want to I want to try
to keep a white a lot of thing for you
that's why I wear black socks okay well
I can't wait black socks if I have on
like dark sneakers oh well I mean I
can't wait white socks with dark
sneakers now I have a sorry if I have
white sneakers I need white socks really
yeah I guess yeah I have mostly white
sneakers no offense no but I think a lot
of those guys that that's what ends up
happening so I think the way to do it is
and I haven't figured out how to get
into the game yet is you get to a
certain point when you're at the height
of your your earning power I think you
should already be planning your graceful
exit from this business because it's
social strata so I think rather than
going out and buying flashy [ __ ] [ __ ]
hovercraft and all the dumb [ __ ] that
that artists bye bye start buying rental
units I'm not a helicopter I'd love to
but I can't I can't justify like
maintaining it to if I can playing this
I got a kid now man I can write smash
cut you know what's cool is I'm doing
Irvine yeah on Tuesday and Wednesday you
know that's like you know it's like two
hours of traffic oh yeah I'm reading a
little 22 shut the hell of a bob
Bob go right over it like 25 that was
[ __ ] awesome it is yeah
oh my god dude [ __ ] I did my time I did
my time not [ __ ] do it my meeting for
yet another comedian talking about how
horrific the traffic was there in the
first 10 minutes how about I go up there
and be the comic who's in a good mood
that's what people are coming out so I
was 10-minute helicopter rod oh yeah
that's fantastic
alright up and [ __ ] over and this is
the thing way table and like you look at
the parking struggle and right on the
roof of the improv now we're trying to
find you got to call up it's like I'm
look every time you fly you learned
something so I'm learning this time is
like they'll have this all these
helipads so you can even go beyond the
airports because I was thinking like
John Wayne it's close by but then
there's another one that's even closer
but then there's like these helipads on
top of buildings and all just all around
me but you have to you just have to call
them it's in telling you gonna fly down
a solo no no no no I I don't have
confidence to fly at night I I fly solo
during the day but at night it's just a
whole different ballgame and I'll never
forget one night doing a night flight I
was with an instructor and how you
transition the airspace at LAX is either
you fly under you know underneath it but
you you're along the coastline flying
like 100 feet off the water which is
awesome and scary [ __ ] right and or you
fly over Sepulveda over like those glow
stick things it like you know I think
it's like mm I've only done it once like
2,000 feet or above so at night we flew
over over the Sepulveda one and you know
it's [ __ ] freaky because there's all
these jets coming in that if you're in
the same altitude altitude would t-bone
you so we're flying oh yeah man I go
I'll pick that Airport that's crazy and
how big these planes are landing here
and he just goes yeah there's one right
there
and it was like almost underneath us but
because when you're looking down and
there's not a lot of street lights and
just the lights from the city I didn't
see like a [ __ ] you know whole 749
740 said whatever the [ __ ] they fly now
I don't know what the numbers are
anymore
it was like going right underneath us
and I was just like
oh you didn't see that no but he did
this right this is when I was getting my
license so I didn't know how to to look
for [ __ ] and everything so night flying
is an entirely entirely different game
so I'll be flying down with one of my
instructors so but if it was if it was
like the if it was the [ __ ]
summertime though but every time it's
gonna by the end of the show it's gonna
be dark out but that is a goal of mine
right who is I would love to fly solo
now let me ask you this how much does it
cost it would cost you did do that to
fly non-exempt of like rental vehicle
hands it's like 300 bucks I mean it's
it's a decent amount of money but it's
also like no no no no no no no no no no
no nothing like that it's like 300 bucks
and then and it's fun and then I get
another like I'll get like another I'm
gonna get another two hours under my
belt no lying at night and I got this
killer [ __ ] instructor right now my
auto rotations are the best they've ever
been with it basically so we'll fly
around now and he just sort of like
he'll just I don't know ago you know
engine failure and then you just have to
pick a [ __ ] spot and you know you just
I mean we don't take it all way down to
the ground and I land on somebody's
[ __ ] front yard what I have learned
so much I always had great instructors
but this guy that I have now is he's
really got my confidence back up again
where for me to go solo and everything
would be you know I would have the
confidence to do it but I like but
what's good is I'm super [ __ ]
cautious I'm not one of those people you
know with the [ __ ] nine oh two one oh
look at my face you know show up with
like a [ __ ] scar Jers know there's a
lot of people that get they get there
they get their license and once they get
their license they stop their training
and because got it well because they
know how to fly and then you know and
then they just they just start flying
around alright yeah
the flyer parents yeah then when they
came out here and visited but I also did
that with like an instructor and that
was with a impress your parents blown
away that uh they definitely had a good
time they're very conservative people so
you know something you don't necessarily
know right what they're thinking then
we're going crazy they walk going crazy
they were just like nothing like that
was nice it was very uh my heart is
beating out of my chest right now
no mic my dad had a pilot's license as
apostles because once you get it so like
he no no no he had fixed wings so he
knew a lot of the [ __ ] that was going on
so you know but my mother thought it was
awesome she loved it and wasn't scared
at all my dad I think because he had a
license understood that probably more
the danger of it and they're the type of
[ __ ] so he probably thought it was a
little squirrely when we were a hundred
feet off the [ __ ] water flying on any
you know the Jets at whatever but I'd
say it's one the great things that I've
done in my [ __ ] adult life and I don't
know but we're not here to talk about
meek we're here to talk about you we've
already done an hour and fifteen minutes
just like that hey can I can I come down
the night of your take dude I want
nothing more than okay come down there
alright well some people you know they'd
like me I'd be like no I don't want
anybody there nobody I [ __ ] know so
it's just one more thing we're gonna do
like you know I'm gonna come on able to
be brought from offstage I have another
comedian opening for me again at Frankie
quinones who does the troll outfit
videos and he usually towards the Craig
and I so I'm gonna have someone bring me
onstage from offstage you got that
[ __ ] voice dear oh yeah I'll
definitely do it oh yeah I mean just
double check my schedule I'm 99% sure
I'm in town right and go forever 11th
February 11th I Sunday Lee yeah what do
I got I got Reno I got Santa Barbara
then I guess something like the Patrice
O'Neal benefit towards the end month oh
man
that's right I met Patrice's mom and
sister with you that was that was
[ __ ] amazing oh yeah that was great
away the best they're the best
hey so I'll uh I'll tell you this when
you do sound check just make sure
speaking of Patrice because I'm
he did some taping and the sound wasn't
right and when it came time for him to
do his taping you know they thought he
was a pain in the ass but he was like
this sound isn't right and he was like I
want to be the loudest thing in the room
so make sure your monitors so you know
you got it just make sure that is right
right if that's [ __ ] right then it's
like yeah your lightsaber is totally on
and you know do you know that deal if
you get up there and you can't [ __ ]
hear yourself thank God knows when you
go to tape there's always somebody who
[ __ ] something like that oh I thought
it'd be good to just have the sound way
down you know just make sure all of that
shit's right and then go up there and
kill it oh yeah I've never seen you so
[ __ ] nervous I'm anxious and I know
you are it's going to be great if you
were doing it tonight I could tell this
whole podcast yeah all sigh don't be
loud because I know your daughters leave
it okay I know dude
and I'm tired and a little bit hungover
but other than that a little bit yeah I
always went like this whenever I have
one of those coming up I just feel like
just can you jet just bring me up now in
my slippers right so I just go out there
and just [ __ ] it that just do it the
waiting was what's hard right that's the
worst all right well that's the podcast
dude I'm so psyched so then I can't wait
to do this I can't wait to see it and I
can't wait to promote the hell out of it
and I can't wait to see you finally
getting your name out there and
everybody knowing how [ __ ] hilarious
got four [ __ ] kids they're gonna be
in college at some point right out of
college so I know you got a nice spread
they're making it 24 - 7 yeah 20:47 they
go 24/7 there all right man todrick's
everybody once again
yeah the satellite la dot-com for
tickets I'll definitely be tweeting this
out
February 11th it's a Sunday 7:30 and
9:30 in Silver Lake Los Angeles it's the
weekend after the Superbowl so you know
you can be all depressed that football
is over for another six months come on
out and see one of the best comics I
know all right
Podcast go [ __ ] yourselves I'll check in
on you on Thursday
now geez